You know, Thanksgiving is coming up soon.
Sure, but I don't know too much about it.
We have a different Thanksgiving celebration in Korea.
Here in the US, we always celebrate Thanksgiving on the fourth Thursday of November.
Right, so it's next Thursday then?
Yes. I really like Thanksgiving because it's a family holiday and it's not overly commercialized.
What do you mean?
Well, it's not all about spending lots of money on presents,...
...and you are not inundated with television advertising around Thanksgiving the way you are around Christmas time.
I see what you mean.
On Thanksgiving, the main focus is to get together with your family and have a huge, delicious meal.
Oh, I see.